[Music]
you know what are the chances news
submitted by you can't guard me a random
in-and-out burger found on the streets
of New York turn into a silly mystery
online it doesn't sound silly it's not
solely me so somebody didn't that was
1007 under miles away and where's that
what's the closest in and out to the New
York's wait I want to know what the
story is
sorry yeah so yeah Barbour so the
closest in and out is on the west coast
right like it the furthest it goes to
east is Texas yep and so because of that
Ellen this burger was found impeccable
and like an impeccable condition no it's
the person that really took care of it
yeah the transportation method perhaps
by a Gulfstream jet okay why would they
leave it on the floor so this is a big
mystery cuz it's like how the [ __ ] like
the nearest one is like in Texas it
should so far Oh
a rich person was flying over it does
and in it fell off of the plane and he
just saved the wrapper and put it on
like McDonald's no in and out yeah this
is an in-n-out burger I think one of us
got [ __ ] rich that's what I think cuz
this is the kind of [ __ ] I would pull oh
you would I wish nothing but riches for
you cuz I want you and Joe dude [ __ ]
like this I'm saying go wild with my you
follow the pours like this the ports I
wouldn't waste food like that I would
put it on a table for them this guy
named Lincoln he is a Brooklyn based
creative director and he knows in-n-out
burgers he [ __ ] knows them cuz he
grew up in Santa Monica and he has lived
in New York for only nine years and so
he's like he bid it loves in and out so
he knows like this is not fake like Oh
fight it no no no it was like detective
he pulled out like his pocket he did the
you think you did it yeah my magnifying
glass
tell of the Thousand Island dressing yep
he's a guy that's in and out right
there's a got a real fan no only real
fans can hear the burger there are all
these different theories and so I will
read them to you the first one is the
burger is some kind of art installation
that was thereby dropped there by Banksy
or some would-be Banksy baby Nazi
another cool one is some fancy company
hosted and in and out pop-up or had the
means to fly in and out into New York
and that an attendee dropped it after
leaving the party drop that looked
pleased and it looks too perfect to be
dropped it was not so it's considered
potentially an art installation because
in an out but if it was [ __ ] Hardee's
and we found it on the West Coast people
died God Jesus Christ I'm saying it's
the branding for sure so then the next
one is that it was a prop from a TV or
film shoot with crass with a craft
services burger dressed up as an in and
out in and in and out rapper the next
one is that it was from Queens own PD's
burger which has been described as an
in-and-out knockoff and because they're
saying that they have the California
fries and similar paper wrappers so
someone wrapped the in-and-out wrapper
and left it on the floor like that
that's what they're saying and then
another one or theories another one is
that this was ridiculous but and alleged
early 70s airplane hijacker DB cooper is
still alive and is now deliberately
dropping burgers on the East Coast
instead of accidentally dropping tightly
bundled $20 bills in Southwest
Washington I'm surprised nobody just ate
it and another one the bar DP Cooper
just died by the way big boy I want to
take a bit I would just be like in and
out I've never seen you eat food up but
look how perfect look at how perfect it
blowing a dirtiest fluid I ever seen my
life every day
don't play we'll play enough sure like
he knows what orifices he's sticking
them in you know I mean alright guys
well guess what I have the answer but
the last one that I wanted to what was
the last one what's the last one
Johnny sure it was solved yeah so the
last ones kikuna said that this burgers
just the seed and if properly planted it
would eventually grow into a fully
functional in and out I liked it when
can I leave this video I don't want this
world I've I like a mystery it's like
the ending of Inception because I'm
gonna tell you close your earholes I
just thought it was so cool then we
don't know well actually before I tell
you the answer the guy who found the
burger started making shirts and will
donate the proceeds to yes it's like
Jamaica Queens with the internet logo I
like that shirt but look how perfect
that Burger looked on the floor though
time to spoil the mystery uh very good
Lincoln had received many DMS from
people claiming that that was their
burger but then after he investigated or
like wanted proof from them like they'd
always fell through so but this time he
finally got the answer because this
fifteen year old girl from New York she
she's gonna go far in life sixteen year
old uh she ended up deeming him and
saying hi this is actually my burger you
may not believe me however I came from I
came from a flight that arrived at 5
a.m. from San Diego and then she has the
stories to prove it you know so she
landed she did a red arc she landed so
it's a rock she landed in New York at 5
a.m. but she left from Canada ago she
ended up going to in and out and asking
that or letting them know that they're
about to go as she was about to go on a
really long flight so she ordered three
double double burgers and they told her
in order to preserve the burgers to not
put the sauce and to put the veggies
separate so then she held on to his
brown picking the in and out paper bag
rolled up like a brown lunch bag in her
lap for the entire flight
and so she even gave him proof from her
bank that she budged you know I have
this proof to at the
I didn't eat but she's she lives in New
York and like she's I don't know any
more perfect so then she also has has
this story proof that you know flight
back to New York and then at a certain
time and then she also said how it
because he was like how did it drop so
perfectly but like that I got I don't
understand
so what ended up happening is that she
when she arrives in New York she was
trying to catch a bus and so because she
plays bat minute bat bat mint yeah that
because she plays it like you know she
was able to catch the bus but during
that run the [ __ ] so the barger
assembled itself and it fell
no connect I'm gonna tell you something
the paper bag got soggy at the bottom
and side she uh all three but she caught
two of them she was evil or like her
reflexes are so good that she caught two
of the birds but the third one just
landed there something the guy was like
littered so you need any of them on the
plane well she ate one three I forgot
she did he won on the plane though I
forgot the to him up the pointed for
that she that she um he asked her like
I'll tell are you because you must Miley
short where it's a fall perfectly yeah
not face bladder so she's like five two
or something so he was like all right it
all checks out so it's all that I love
she attributes her speed of catching the
bus it happened and there's no sauce
there's no sauce another coming from him
and he wrote this whole thing well the
point is she's a litter bug that's the
[ __ ] bottom line she left it on the
floor yep she should have taken the
wrapper off do you even had a a
screenshot of one of her dams of her
friends saying like welcome back to the
city the heatwave was waiting for you
and then she goes God one of my in-n-out
burgers fell on the streets of John
and then the person's like I know people
saw in-and-out burger and we're like
what's going on here
and she's like I got so many stairs
because people just like couldn't
believe this is perfect in-n-out burger
was just doing that and then at the end
of it all the writer was saying no
edible yeah he was saying that she very
kindly asked like about the shirt she
ended up saying this also I don't want
to sound greedy but about that shirt I
would totally love one it would be a
nice memory and I would love if your
autographed it for me
he was like of course what about your
family anyone else thought one and she's
like are you sure I want there to be
enough for charity oh that's pretty nice
that's not even greedy I thought she was
gonna be like give me a cut that [ __ ]
was my charity a cut yeah it's a church
it's like flying solo
no as Jews with her family oh my gosh
I will say four and now Burgers was
quite a lot of burger $15 I don't
believe that receipt not having no fries
no milkshake yeah oh she did get a lemon
a she she did mention she this is
important but I found about a lemonade
is this important for your investigation
I believe that she didn't get the fries
because the fries are terrible at
in-n-out I agreed yeah terrible but
they're not the best oh they're terrible
cardboard they're different they're just
my friend they're in-n-out fries you
have to get me animal style to even
survive they're pretty good animal fries
so true that Philly we I guess yeah
really just to get through it it's just
so like them
stale potato yeah that's too bad you're
like no I actually don't see damage
native Kelly I miss old school
McDonald's fries before Morgan Spurlock
ruined it by doing supersize me and then
me tones like we're gonna do vegetable
oh my god
[ __ ] magic bro what we need but all
fight was a child so some kinda fat or
something I'm yeah I feel like they
taste the same no I still think though
the fresh McDonald's fries are the best
they're still the best it's it's not
what it used to be right it used Tommy
Lambert the [ __ ] Michelin star of
french fries yeah there's this hack I
heard on the radio if you want freshly
made fries and this this varies on if
you care about this or not but you just
tell them hey can I have surprised with
no salt oh and then you put the salt
after oh it's tiniest they're always
fresh but oh because they have to make
them fresh because they don't just have
fries saying they're without salt so you
like I'm allergic to salt
are you just a song can I get a burger
salt free fries please thank you but the
one that kills it is cuz they once they
put the salt like they mix it all up so
you're just I don't know maybe put in a
bag and shake it I was with the
girlfriend's family many years ago and
this dis chick thought you were family
members thought they'd be smart by being
like gum
hey I'm allergic to shellfish so can you
make sure that you don't have any of
that and they're like literally
everything here has shellfish we can't
serve you enough so this chick had this
[ __ ] starve through the dinner like
yeah exactly
well they had to that like we can't we
literally can't serve you if you're
allergic you could die here like saying
that you're allergic to things are
you're not it's like because they have
to do this whole crazy prep in the
kitchen and making sure like your food
her like it's like a whole cuz it
combination and things like that I could
barely even give her bread they're just
like so we know they were so scared
after that and like obviously the legal
we don't treat that water right it's got
clam juice on it like we prepare
everything on the sandwich thing so no
way and yeah it was hilarious I
pretended to pass out once oh not a band
camp that I really passed out I got a
shot you know you get shot in middle
school or something whatever I was like
I'm gonna like test I always wanted me
an actress I was like I'm gonna test my
acting ability so I got a shot and then
I was like oh
and I was at the nurses so I just
literally laid down and I passed out and
I thought I just got out of class but
then they like called my mom and they
wouldn't let me go home and then my mom
had to like leave work early I felt
terrible yeah they were like you kid
you're passed out you can't be on a bus
it's like a backward but hey great
actress then you were it worked
[Music]